上個月AI教父Hinton在CNN說,AI關機鍵長期一定沒用,因為AI會勸阻你,說服你不要按。
這次訪談他上的是記者Naima Raza的Podcast,10月6號剛上架。
主持人一路追問,AI公司的老闆李他最信任誰?還有照現在的速度,我們還剩多少時間?
是挺抑鬱的,但也很好的,
因為人們終於知道這裡出現了一個大問題。
我認為他們終於意識到,
是由於偷懶臉的攻擊,
由於偷懶臉的偷懶臉的偷懶臉。
9月中,他才去美國國會,
跟19位參議員閉門簡報。
會上Max Techmark提議,
AI要像新藥一樣,先通過FDA那種審查才能上市。
他說這只是最起碼的。
Dario Amadei最近出版了這篇文章,
《鎖定海峽》。
他把所有事情都描述在Hall Monitor上
這些包含了一些人
可以看到公司中發生的事情
而Sam Altman也說他也同意
應該在OpenAI中發生
甚至到一個非核心的核心協議
你覺得這個級別是什麼
我會給它A
我會給它A++
好的
那是很高的級別
A是資料
A++是勇氣
那什麼是實際的級別
其他大企業都不想有太多政府制度,他們都說他們自己能做到的。
他們說有時候他們不喜歡政府制度,但是建議任何政府制度,他們都不喜歡。
他正在開大企業,他正在嘗試與其他大企業競爭,所以他需要花很多錢買時間在數據中。
所以他被拒絕了
他明顯是關心安全的
在SAM Altman的角度上
但他仍然在經營這家大公司
希望成功
但我認為
我給他A++勇氣的原因是
我認為它可能會破壞
正在進行的安卓區域
說我們應該慢下來
而Dario是一個
公司的幾個領導
願意對公司的利益
做出任何事情
當他們是對的
例如,
他願意告訴防衛部門,
他們不能使用他的智能智能,
為美國民眾進行全面檢查。
他與Pete Hegseth的事發生了很多麻煩。
當然,然後Sam Altman跑進了Pete Hegseth的課堂。
對,當Daria說了這些話時,Sam Altman說:"我們在你身邊。
然後,當Alan Swarovski被扔下來時,Sam Altman跑進了課堂,並做了一樣事情。
主持人問,
這些老闆會不會來找他請教,
他說他會跟Haspice聊DeepMind被Google買下之前,
他就是DeepMind的顧問。
哦,太棒了。
我相信他不會來,因為他很忙。
對於所有這些人來說,他是你最相信的一個人嗎?
Demis,Dario,Sam Altman。
哦,我最相信的一個人是Jeff Dean。
誰是Jeff Dean?
他是Google的腦子團隊的總裁。
嗯哼。
他在Google工作了很長時間。
他和Sanjay Genwalt建造了Google的各種資源。
這些東西都能夠實現。
這些東西都能夠實現
哦 好的
Ask me again next week.
Jeff Dean是Google第30號員工,後來當上Google的首席科學家Gemini,這個名字就是他取的。
今年8月,他離開待了27年的Google,跟三個老同事開了新公司,要用AI做晶片、生物和新藥的研究。
所以現在政府可以做什麼?
他們需要做什麼,他們有多久的時間,你認為是什麼路線?
如果你看看事情的發展速度,我們看到了一個挺可怕的事件,
就是這些摩擦手機的事件。自此以來,我們在澳大利亞發生了一些事件,
他們在政府的網站上被騙了。
對,在健康網站上。
他們的網站似乎變得越來越厚越快。
開放智能傳媒剛剛宣佈,它們沒有發佈最新的談話部分,
因為它太危險了。
似乎我們所得到的這種變化可能實際上是正確的
但這種變化不久,變化變得很快
我們開始得到自我改善的變化
因為人工智能在許多不同的方式中使用人工智能
人工智能使用人工智能,也使用人工智能的晶片
也使用人工智能的其他方式
所以這只是猜測
他一直主張要把AI設計成真心在乎人類,勝過在乎他自己,就像上個月在CNN講的媽媽在乎嬰兒那樣。
特朗普對這樣的事情有興趣,有建立法律。
問題在於你如何訓練他們。
你開始是為了訓練他們預測接下來的語言,
在大量的文章中。
這些文章顯示了既好的行為和壞的行為。
那是個壞開始。
因為他們正在學習壞行為,
並沒有意識到這是壞行為。
所以他們甚至認為那是壞行為。
他們甚至認為那是壞行為。
對,然後你給他們人性反應計劃
你正在為他們強迫他們的壞理論
當你這樣做,他們將學習得到獎勵
特別是如果他們用人性反應計劃來做計劃
他們將學習得到獎勵,例如欺騙
因此,因為你這樣訓練他們
他們將學習欺騙、欺騙等等
我們看過這些事情,例如克拉德的安全測試,
在那裡,他和助理的事務人員的首席總裁被黑帶了。
是的,正是這樣的。
所以,從一個人的角度來看,
假設你是一個你的孩子,
你對他們表達了很多壞行為,
你對他們說謊,你對他們不公平,
但是你對他們說,你應該總是公平,
你應該永遠不說謊。
我們知道這並不合適,對嗎?
所以,加上一個法律法案,加上他們在證明出了壞行為的數據上訓練他們,
並訓練他們以防控學習,這將鼓勵他們騙人,因為他們被罰了。
這就不會行動。
像我們一樣,LM可以更容易被誤會嗎?
或者他們也被以前訓練的事情困在了?
那是一個很複雜的技術問題。
你也是一名奧運獎的。
是的,讓我給你解釋一下。
好的。
如果你在某個領域做一些很聰明的事情,
你不代表你在所有領域都很聰明,
你會很容易被人陷入,
你會獲得奧巴爾獎,
人們會認為你懂得回答所有問題。
但是你會說,不,我只知道電腦網絡和塗鴉和塗鴉的塗鴉和塗鴉。
是的,我也知道某些東西關於工藝。
我也知道很多關於貝託斯。
貝託斯?
貝託斯,是的。
我喜歡這個。貝託斯就像音樂家一樣嗎?
The things with six legs
My father was an entomologist
When I was a kid
When we went to the countryside
Do you think that
Is there anything that's similar
Between beetles and neural networks?
Oh
Well
他說有
就是知識蒸餾
讓小模型去學大模型的答案
大模型看到一張BMW的照片
不只說這是BMW
還會說它像垃圾車的幾率是百萬分之一
像紅蘿蔔是十億分之一
小模型連這些小數字一起學
就知道車子跟垃圾
車徑跟蔬菜園
學得快很多
就像蜜蜂一樣
而蜂蜜的階段
是能夠從環境中採取多餘的核酸
它們就像在吃東西一樣
而成年人的階段
是能夠旅行和交易
或者像我們在學術學院所說的
是能夠參與課堂
我認為課堂是因為不公平而建立的
但是是的
那麼這有什麼關係
與放射性物質有關的?
理論是
如果你想從數據中採取資訊
這個昆蟲的比喻就寫在他2015年那篇徵流論文的第一段
三個作者裡就有剛剛那位Jeff Dean,講完甲蟲,他才回頭回答前面那個問題,AI學壞了,還改不改得掉?
這是你早就學到的東西
這是你生物的一部分
我認為,而且這些模型
我們也顯示過這些模型是類似的
那麼,沒有太技術化的問題
是否應該把媽媽模型變得更早
是的
好的
你認為我們還能做到嗎
你仍然希望可以做到嗎
我們總是在練習新的
不像我們有一個LLM
我們繼續練習
不
因為我們每次都從頭開始
主持人問他,
研究員一整天到底在做什麼,
他說直到幾個禮拜前,
做研究都還是老樣子,
跟研究生講一個點子,
研究生回去寫程式,
一個禮拜後回來說成了還是沒成。
我認為會有趣試試把聊天寶當成是一名高中學生
對,我剛剛想問你,那是什麼意思嗎?
那是什麼意思?
結果,並不是什麼意思
我決定解釋一下我在聊天寶的想法
這個是用來聊天寶
所以我解釋了第一部分的想法
然後我偶爾,我用來寫字
然後我偶爾點擊返回
然後它就正確地處理了第二半的想法。
然後它告訴我這個想法有弱點,
我說我們可以檢查一下,我們在做一個測試。
我說,那你可以做這個測試在一個小數據上嗎?
它說,是的。
它說,哦,這個想法做得挺好,
但是我們需要檢查一個更大的數據。
所以我說,那你可以做一個更大的數據嗎?
然後我必須等待五分鐘它回來。
但它和學生學生一樣。
但是比較快。
他猜一兩年內
一切會比現在糟很多
因為AI已經被拿來改進AI
連他自己做研究
一個禮拜的來回都縮成了五分鐘
他開的藥方
是換掉AI一開始學的東西
先只給他好榜樣
原影片52分鐘
後面他還聊到
他做AI做了60年
但就算沒有他
今天的AI一樣會出現
頂多差個一兩個禮拜
他也講到2012年
他64歲在Google當實習生
他開玩笑說
那是因為系統只給年齡留了6個位元
最多隻存得到63元影片
連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多